and are they constantly looking for new
animators always always
right yeah yeah i i guess it's because
if you're not getting paid like a lot
it's hard to find
yeah so do it right yeah uh actually if
you're
too expensive so okay we don't have the
budget stories so
we are going to find someone else you
mentioned twitter as well is that how
they find a lot of the the newer talent
yeah twitter also because uh now on
twitter i think you know the web
generation
yeah some quite uh foreign anime
animators
who yeah welcome pretty
pretty much i'm just wondering so is
there
this much of a shortage of animators in
japan that they have to look
literally on twitter they're doing what
we do and just browsing twitter and
being like you
you seem to have a guy all by
recommendation by uh
by other senpai oh i had walk with this
young guy
he's pretty scared for oh um
i will have worked with this we had some
problem but
you can manage to work on it so you have
depends i see if you work with a foreign
people you you know that
they're learning by themselves right by
themselves and they're doing all the
the best that they want and they accept
the amount of money
and so uh if they
they there is an accident it's normal
because they're learning by their self
and yeah you have to teach them how to
get better yeah yeah yeah because i
actually have like an artist friend who
used to like
draw stuff for me like years ago yeah i
ended up being an animator for black
clover
yeah same here like i i had a like
an artist who was following an animator
and then they just showed up working on
sword arts online yeah
right yeah shout out to kate shout out
to k animations yeah it's just weird how
that like i didn't think like
i'd always heard of like the webgen
animators right yeah we call them but
like i've never actually like
seen it happen so when i saw it happen i
was like oh wow they actually use
twitter as like a form of
like auditioning yeah yeah exactly
actually i think the
the flashpoint we can take like that was
uh maybe at
the bottom what is that 65
oh you have a oh that fight yeah
it's the moment sasuke versus sasuke
naruto versus momishi yeah
yeah and in fact the episode director
was a
sikhi co-son and he's a chinese guy who
success to
call a lot of foreign animators and he
was by himself doing the assistant
projection by himself or trying to
contact a lot of animators check their
car
to put some correction and i think
he has spent two months at the studio
but because of him he could manage a lot
of animators to work on this episode
and the episode 65 of balto was a master
class yeah i mean that was
my favorite fight yeah i've seen the
fight i don't know anything but no i
haven't seen i haven't seen borrowed so
i've just seen that fight actually
and that was by far like the best fights
of the year in my opinion right
and with uh this explicit it's proved
okay
foreign animators can also work on
japanese animation
but you have problems also of about
communication
you have some you have a staff who
have to speak english or if they can
speak japanese it's okay
or sometimes you have some mistakes by
them but
yes it's uh if you work with foreign
some it's happened but uh if you
correct them and they will do their best
to uh
what would you say is the best way for
let's say a young animator
to get involved in the anime industry
now well now like i said this depends
the experience you want if you
want just walk we just want to work on
one piece or just once
okay so twitter it will be okay i think
uh or i want just a one year experience
so i okay see if you want to come to
japan
you have to find a studio could prove
you a visa
right you couldn't believe groups yeah
yeah yeah
and if you want a career i want to work
in japan i want to live in japan i want
to marry the
japanese girl i want that ideal weave
life
yeah and so in order for you to assume
you're going to have enough time and
money
to marry your japanese girls i was
thinking of asking i don't know how
personal it is because you mentioned
that like obviously the senpai's they
have a family and whatnot
how the [ __ ] does anyone date who
because
it sounds like you guys never leave the
office how do you do it you bring them
to the office you're like hold on i'm
gonna do a keyframe i'll answer that
question
that's a bit like that have you ever
brought a date to the office
but um actually yes so i'm working at
the studio and also i'm
so sometimes i'm working on two shows at
the same time
so i'm working on the movie and
sometimes again how do you find the time
because unless you're dating like
another key animator yeah yeah
yo she's two blocks down she's like
three tables away
actually i i prefer not data to the wall
right about animations for
going to bit kill my passion i will say
i prefer to
talk other things uh yeah so oh yeah of
course i mean yeah
you have a lot of your life revolving
around yeah i'm sure you want to break
because i'm
i'm thinking animation i i walk
animation i [ __ ] animation